ladies and gentlemen distinguished
guests
dear friends welcome to the 14th edition
of the european development days
this year's meeting on the green deal
for sustainable future
could not come at a more crucial time
the covet 19 pandemic has just
shown us how directly the health of our
people
and the health of our planet are
interconnected
of course it was already clear prior to
the pandemic
that climate change is the defining
challenge of our time
it therefore was a top priority for our
commission from day one
with our european green deal we want to
lead the way
for green and inclusive transformation
of our economies and our societies
and the pandemic has made this task even
more urgent
we have spoken a lot about the link
between
biodiversity loss and covet 19.
now we must move to action
and this is why just recently at the
global health summit
the commission together with the italian
g20 presidency
put the one health approach
in the center of the rome declaration
also economically this is the right
thing to do
the harm that we are doing to the earth
climate and environment is also harming
the well-being of
billions of people worldwide and this is
why it is right and also prudent
to invest quickly and boldly in the
health of our planet
this year's edition of the european
development days
takes place as we prepare the road to
the un
biodiversity conference in kunming
there we want to agree on a powerful new
global biodiversity framework
a framework that mobilizes all citizens
and all parts of government and society
and i'm sure these european development
days
will build momentum towards kunming
with more than 170 organizations from
across the world
this exchange of youth will be a truly
global one
and the next two days are a unique
opportunity to share ideas and to share
experiences
and it will help to inspire new
partnerships
and of course to find innovative
solutions
the development days are not only about
ideas
but also about action the european union
is ready to work with partners to
address both
the biodiversity loss and the climate
crisis
that's why the european union is working
towards global commitments
to protect 30 percent of our land and
our sea this is a goal for the
biodiversity cup
15 in china and we are also
aiming to increase climate ambitions
in glasgow the european union is
determined to turn these challenges
into economic opportunities the question
how to ensure green growth will be key
to speed up global efforts against
climate change
and the loss of biodiversity we as a
european union we want to lead the way
when the answers are formulated in
kunming
and dear friends we have seen our young
generation
taking to the streets they are standing
up and putting the planet's health first
and rightly so because their future is
at stake
their voices must have a significant
impact
on our policies and actions and
therefore i am delighted
that we have a remarkable group of
talented young leaders
with us in this opening ceremony
this year we want young people to shape
the discussion
and beyond this i know that commissioner
yota orpilin's
youth sounding board initiative will
open new possibilities
to hear directly from young people
we need you we need the young with your
energy
your drive and your vision to take on
the huge challenge facing your
generation
because we all know it will take courage
leadership and political will to push
for the greater good
but it is worth any effort and you can
count on europe
so let's get started